people actually reported her to the  police for a hate crime yeah just by  your presence in that school that's the  problem with hate crime legislations  like who defines hate and I know they  answered that who defines hate the  people you least want to  so you know you want hate crime  legislation you just better keep in mind  who's going to Define what constitutes  hate and then you think about the people  you're enabling these rat Finks these  people who didn't learn not to uh  tattletail on their peers when they were  children who run to totalitarian  authority to wield their resentful power  now that's all part of the legal code  it's like well we'll see where that goes  well we know where it goes It goes so  that you know  demented half-wit resentful narcissists  can rat out Kate verbal sing to the  police yes yeah well that's not good not  at all and who knows where it'll end up